and I walk back to Long crime daily
everybody we finish off in Brooklyn with
yet another defamation case where a
preacher is suing a radio host for 50
million dollars Lamar Miller Whitehead
known as The Bling Bishop is suing radio
personality Tarsha Nicole Jones for
comments that she made on her Morning
Show the preacher was robbed in July
while live streaming a sermon losing
over a million dollars in jewelry and
according to the lawsuit Jones made
false statements on her Radio Show in
September calling the bishop a quote
drug dealer and claiming that he was
using the church to hide old drug money
the suit also accuses Jones of saying
the preacher quote assaulted the young
lady when he allegedly grabbed a young
woman by the neck mid-service Whitehead
was handcuffed after that incident but
released by police hours later right now
Jones doesn't have a lawyer listed in
court records and he hasn't spoken
publicly on the lawsuit
Terry we have seen a lot of defamation
lawsuits filed in the last few months
many involving celebrities and just
because you file a lawsuit doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
win one right I mean can you tell us a
little bit more about that Jesse this is
an interesting case and it has multiple
twists and turns it also makes you think
about before you say something on air
many people were very skeptical about
this robbery some even blamed Bishop
Whitehead for being ostentatious with
his jewelry and other valuables but
Whitehead thought that several people
went way too far in their commentary
he's suing Jones for several statements
she made on September 13th when she was
on air speaking to thousands of viewers
according to the complaint Jones said
that Whitehead was a drug dealer as you
mentioned and that she is he's using all
of this old money that he got from his
drugs in the church I actually spoke to
Bishop Whitehead's attorney his name is
Brian Ponder who confirmed that
additional lawsuits have already been
filed against people who allegedly made
defamatory remarks including a lawsuit
against air personality Larry Reed
Ponder said that he keeps a running list
get this of people who he may sue for
those remarks that they're making it
sounds like there may be quite a few
people on that list but Ponder explained
exactly why Tarsha Jones is at the top
of the list he mentioned the
requirements to bring a defamation case
including the need to show actual malice
when a public figure is involved take a
listen
these you know these allegations are not
couched and you know being alleged and
and radio personalities they they know
how to have commentary that's commentary
versus uh defamatory statements that are
maliciously made uh to cause significant
damage to someone but the way she made
these comments uh were in fact with
malice and uh very calculated to cause
damage is almost as if she had some type
of Vendetta against Bishop Whitehead and
um yeah it's very unfortunate it's very
very damaging I don't you know you would
think because this lady Miss Jones
um was previously reprimanded at another
employee for making
um you know statements that were
improper so you would think she would
have learned a lesson but apparently not
but yes definitely I think without
question the particular statements we
pulled out were the ones that were very
malicious and without questioning our
opinion she and her employer Paramount
would be found libel
you know Jesse I also asked Ponder if he
could prove actual damages which as you
know is a required element in a
defamation case he confirmed to me that
after Jones's remarks several of
Whitehead's investors stopped investing
their money so it sounds like there
could be real damages in this case Brian
again we've seen multiple defamation
lawsuits in recent years Johnny Depp
against Amber Heard the case that was
brought by the families of the Sandy
Hook victims against Alex Jones do you
think that people are just suing for the
sake of suing I know anybody could sue
anybody for anything but is that what's
happening here I mean people in this
country are very litigious so that could
be a part of it but you listed those
major cases maybe people are just
becoming more and more aware of this
being a a way to recruit recruit sorry
losses especially when their reputation
is damaged say what you want to say
about the bling Bishop to ostentatious
too many agility maybe this is not the
way the Bible should be
um preached but when you go after a
public figure in this way and they lose
money they lose sponsors they lose
people going to their Church the law
does afford them with a way of recouping
those losses he lost a million dollars
when he was robbed now he's looking for
50. I think he might be uh making out on
top at the end of the day when it comes
to this case especially if they can
prove actual malice and it seems like a
possibility here I think the biggest
takeaway is defamation lawsuits very
important but each one is pretty
independent just because it was
successful or unsuccessful in one case
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
get the same result and another and I
think that probably is the best takeaway
from learning about these cases Brian
Terry great to have you on thanks so
much for joining us here on Long crime
daily we're gonna see you next time
discuss Justice